"Tornado crossing the road."
"(brüllt:) Look at the house!"
Es ist das klassische Szenario
eines Katastrophenfilms.
Ein riesiges Unglück
kommt über die Welt.
Überall sterben Menschen.
Häuser stürzen ein,
und Landschaften verändern sich
innerhalb kürzester Zeit.
Alles ist vorbei.
Denkt man.
Dann aber taucht diese eine Heldin
oder dieser eine Held auf,
macht ein paar kluge Dinge,
und am Ende ist alles wieder gut.
Happy End - so ist es im Film.
In der Realität sieht es
allerdings ganz anders aus.
Der menschengemachte Klimawandel
wird zunehmend zu einer Bedrohung.
Wetterextreme, Waldbrände,
Überschwemmungen.
Alles das kommt immer häufiger vor.
Das Problem ist nur:
Wenn es so weitergeht,
dann kann uns keine Heldin
oder kein Held mehr retten,
denn dann ist es vorbei.
Aber muss es tatsächlich
so weit kommen?
Stehen wir wirklich
kurz vor der Klimaapokalypse?
Was passiert,
wenn tatsächlich alles kippt?
Darum geht's jetzt.
(Dynamische Musik)
Inzwischen haben wir uns
fast daran gewöhnt.
Irgendeine neue Studie
oder ein Bericht erscheinen,
und die Überschriften dazu
ähneln sich.
(Er liest vor.)
Oder einfach nur: "Es brennt".
Egal welche Wissenschaftlerin
oder welchen Wissenschaftler
aus der Klimaforschung man fragt,
fast alle sagen übereinstimmend:
Es muss etwas passieren.
Mehr dazu ist unten
in der Infobox verlinkt,
auch zu der Studienlage.
Ja, es gibt auch einige,
die die Zukunft weniger düster sehen
und optimistischer sind.
Aber selbst die sagen, das Tempo,
das die Erderwärmung angenommen hat,
ist außergewöhnlich hoch,
es muss dringend verlangsamt werden.
Dass es daneben auch Leute gibt,
die komplett leugnen,
dass es so was wie einen
menschengemachten Klimawandel gibt
oder dass CO2 schädlich wäre,
wisst ihr wohl auch.
Genau deshalb hab ich einen
Faktencheck zu dem Thema gemacht.
Den findet ihr oben auf dem i.
So weit ist das erst mal klar.
Aber wo liegen
eigentlich die Schwierigkeiten?
Das sollten wir uns anschauen,
bevor wir einen düsteren Blick
auf ein Katastrophenszenario werfen.
In der Debatte
rund um den Klimawandel
ist immer wieder
von "Kipppunkten" die Rede.
Tatsächlich kann man
diesen Ausdruck wörtlich nehmen.
Stellen wir uns
dieses Dominospiel vor.
Die Steine sind alle ordentlich
aufgereiht und stehen entspannt,
bis der hinterste Stein
angestoßen wird.
Er kippt nach vorne
und stößt den nächsten Stein um.
Der den Nächsten
und so weiter und so fort,
bis am Schluss alle umgekippt sind.
Alle Steine liegen am Boden.
Beim Domino sieht das ganz nett aus.
Wenn es um das Klima geht,
ist das anders.
Als Kipppunkte werden vereinfacht
die Momente bezeichnet,
ab denen ein bestimmter Bereich
in unserem Ökosystem
so verändert wird,
dass man die Veränderung
nicht mehr rückgängig machen kann.
Wie bei dem Dominostein,
wenn er umgefallen ist,
kann er auch nicht mehr
von alleine aufstehen.
So ist das auch bei den Kipppunkten.
Und diese Veränderung
stößt an einer anderen Stelle
auch wieder eine Veränderung an
und die wieder eine andere.
Die Folge ist eine Kettenreaktion,
die massive Veränderungen
mit sich bringt.
Und das Entscheidende, nicht einfach
rückgängig gemacht werden kann.
Weil das wahrscheinlich
noch zu abstrakt ist,
schauen wir uns das
an konkreten Beispielen an.
Nämlich an den
ganz realen Kipppunkten,
die die Wissenschaft ausgemacht hat.
In der Wissenschaft
geht man davon aus,
dass es auf der Erde momentan
insgesamt 16
verschiedene Kipppunkte gibt.
Zu diesen 16 Punkten
gehören unter anderem:
Die sind alle stark gefährdet, wenn's
auf der Erde immer wärmer wird.
Gleichzeitig haben sie
großen Einfluss auf das Klima.
Während die Forschung sich
bei den Korallenriffen
noch nicht ganz einig darüber ist,
wie sich deren Absterben
auf das Klima auswirkt,
sieht das bei anderen Kipppunkten
ganz anderes aus.
Nehmen wir die Permafrostböden.
Das sind Böden,
die dauerhaft gefroren sind.
In Deutschland gibt es
so etwas nicht,
aber dafür
auf der Nordhalbkugel umso mehr.
Rund ein Viertel
der gesamten Nordhalbkugel
ist von Permafrostböden überzogen,
vor allem in Alaska und Sibirien.
Das ändert sich momentan
aber sehr stark.
In Sibirien etwa tauen
immer größere Flächen des Bodens auf.
Zum einen wegen Rodungen und Bränden.
Zum anderen aber auch,
weil es immer wärmer wird.
Das Problem dabei ist,
die Böden speichern in sich
riesige Mengen
an organischem Material.
Vor allem abgestorbene Reste
von Pflanzen und Lebewesen,
die da vor Hunderten, Tausenden
Jahren mal abgelagert wurden.
Taut der Boden auf,
wird dieses Material freigegeben.
Das Ergebnis ist,
riesige Mengen an CO2 werden frei.
Wir sprechen nicht
von ein paar 1.000 Tonnen.
Das Alfred-Wegener-Institut
in Potsdam hat berechnet,
dass die Permaböden
rund 1,7 Billionen Tonnen
Kohlenstoff speichern.
Wird der in die Atmosphäre geblasen,
wird es auf der Erde
deutlich wärmer als jetzt.
Und zwar wirklich deutlich!
Bei mehr Wärme sind wir direkt
beim nächsten Kipppunkt:
dem ewigen Eis,
das nicht mehr so ewig ist.
In der Arktis und der Antarktis
ist ein Großteil des Wassers
das ganze Jahr gefroren.
Dazu gibt es riesige Eisberge,
die zu einem Großteil
aus Süßwasser bestehen.
Das birgt gleich drei Gefahren:
Erstens, wenn das Eis schmilzt,
steigt der Meeresspiegel.
Das passiert schon eine ganze Weile.
Der Weltklimarat rechnet deshalb
mit einem Anstieg
des globalen Meeresspiegels
um einen Meter bis 2100.
Das ist die optimistische Variante.
Die zweite Gefahr,
wenn die Sonne auf die Erde scheint,
wird sie vom Eis
besonders gut reflektiert.
Ist das Eis weg,
passiert das weniger.
Die Sonne trifft auf das Wasser
und wärmt es auf,
mit verheerend Folgen
für die Strömungen.
Ähnlich sieht es
bei der dritten Gefahr aus,
wenn neben dem gefrorenen Meer
auch die Eisberge tauen,
dann gerät sehr viel Süßwasser
in die Meere.
Das kann unter anderem
die Strömungen verändern.
Das bringt uns zum
nächsten Kipppunkt: dem Golfstrom.
Der Golfstrom ist,
vereinfacht gesagt,
eine Art Wärmepumpe,
die gewährleistet,
dass es unter anderem
in Europa nicht zu kalt wird.
Über den Golfstrom wird
warmes Wasser vom Golf von Mexiko
über den Atlantik
bis zu uns gepumpt, dort abgekühlt
und wieder zurückgetrieben.
Dieses System sorgt dafür,
dass die kalten Polarwinde vom Meer
nicht mit voller Wucht
auf das Festland treffen,
sondern vorher aufgewärmt werden.
Dank des Golfstroms ist das Klima
bei uns relativ mild.
Ohne ihn würde es etwa
in Skandinavien oft zugehen
wie in Sibirien.
Verlangsamt der Golfstrom
sich aber durch den Klimawandel
oder wird komplett gestoppt,
könnten wir in eine neue Eiszeit
zurückgeworfen werden.
Paradoxerweise
trotz der Erderwärmung.
Die würde dafür
in anderen Regionen zuschlagen.
Da wäre es dann deutlich wärmer.
Daran seht ihr, wenn sich
an einem Kipppunkt was verändert,
kann das direkt oder auch indirekt
Auswirkungen auf andere Punkte haben.
Ähnlich wie beim Amazonas,
durch dessen Vernichtung
riesige Mengen CO2
frei werden würden,
die sich ebenfalls
auf das Klima auswirken.
Es gibt Leute, die sagen:
Alles halb so wild.
Solche Veränderungen
hat es immer schon gegeben,
die Erde kommt damit klar,
reguliert sich selbst.
Das ist gar nicht so falsch.
So ist es im Laufe der Jahrhunderte
und Jahrtausende immer gewesen.
Aber das Gefährliche
ist Geschwindigkeit,
in der sich grade alles ändert.
Das war so noch nie da.
Mehr dazu in der Infobox.
Im sogenannten
Klimaabkommen von Paris
haben sich deshalb Ende 2015
knapp 200 Staaten dazu verpflichtet,
die Erderwärmung
im Vergleich zum Jahr 1850
deutlich unter zwei Grad zu halten.
Damit, das war damals die Annahme,
könnte verhindert werden,
dass die Kipppunkte aktiviert werden.
Allerdings, dieses Zwei-Grad-Ziel
reicht wohl nicht aus,
um unumkehrbare Folgen zu verhindern.
Das schreibt der Weltklimarat
in seinem aktuellen Bericht.
Die neue Marke stattdessen ist:
maximal 1,5 Grad.
In diesem Sachstandsbericht,
rund 4.000 Seiten ist er lang,
beschreibt der Weltklimarat
dazu fünf mögliche Szenarien
bis Ende des Jahrhunderts.
Zwei dieser Szenarien
sind einigermaßen optimistisch
und gehen davon aus, dass die Welt
es irgendwie hinbekommt.
Eins ist noch einigermaßen okay,
zwei sind sehr negativ.
Eins davon ist so unrealistisch,
dass wir uns das nicht anschauen.
Aber das andere
passt sehr gut zur Frage:
Was passiert,
wenn wir den Klimawandel
nicht in den Griff bekommen?
Das Worst-Case-Szenario sozusagen.
Wir befinden uns im Jahr 2100.
Die Menschheit
hat es nicht geschafft,
den Klimawandel und die Erderwärmung
zu stoppen oder zu verlangsamen.
Viele Kipppunkte wurden aktiviert,
oder die Aktivierung
steht kurz bevor.
Das Klimaziel von zwei Grad
oder von 1,5 Grad
wurde komplett verfehlt.
Stattdessen ist die Erderwärmung
seit 1850 um 3,6 Grad gestiegen.
Das hat massive Folgen.
Zum Beispiel für das Ökosystem.
Das ist durch die schnelle Erwärmung
komplett durcheinandergeraten.
Große Teile Afrikas
sind unbewohnbar geworden.
Vor allem in den Ländern in der Mitte
des Kontinents herrscht Dürre.
Grundwasser gibt es keines mehr.
Ähnlich sieht es in Teilen
des Nahen Ostens und Asiens aus,
aber auch in Regionen Amerikas.
Europa bleibt davon
einigermaßen verschont.
Aber auch bei uns sind
die Verhältnisse extremer geworden.
Ein Hitzesommer
folgt auf den nächsten.
Der Grundwasserspiegel sinkt ab,
sodass viele Wälder
kurz vor dem Kollaps stehen.
Gleichzeitig nehmen
die Wetterextreme zu.
Jedes Jahr wird Europa
durch monsunartige Regenfälle
von Überschwemmungen geplagt.
Besonders betroffen sind die Regionen
rund um die Küsten,
auch in anderen Teil der Erde.
Durch den Anstieg des Meeresspiegels
und Fluten
sind Städte wie New York oder Tokio
teilweise unbewohnbar geworden.
Dazu kommen Stürme, Hurrikans
und andere Extremwetterereignisse,
die nicht mehr
nur alle paar Jahre stattfinden,
sondern teilweise mehrmals im Jahr.
Das trifft vor allem
ärmere Regionen der Welt.
Die Folgen sind dramatisch.
Rund eine halbe Milliarde Menschen
sind auf der Flucht
vor Dürre und Hitze.
Hitzewellen kommen jetzt fast
40-mal häufiger vor als noch 2021.
Die Frage ist nur:
Wohin sollen die Menschen gehen?
Laut dem Szenario
ist die Weltbevölkerung inzwischen
von heute acht auf zwölf Milliarden
Menschen angewachsen.
Die verursachen zum einen
noch mehr CO2,
zum anderen müssen sie alle
irgendwo wohnen und zu essen haben,
vor allem zu trinken.
Millionen Menschen zieht es
aus dem globalen Süden
in den kühleren Norden.
Gleichzeitig kommt es
zu Konflikten um Trinkwasser.
Im Nahen Osten werden schon
Kriege um Wasser geführt,
wie das früher wegen Öl der Fall war.
Nicht nur deshalb
gibt es Auseinandersetzungen.
Weil jedes Land für sich mit
den Folgen des Klimawandels kämpft,
ist eine internationale
Zusammenarbeit kaum noch Thema.
Überall herrschen
Nationalismus und Abschottung.
Für die Wirtschaft ist das Gift.
Der internationale Handel bricht ein.
Es fehlen Rohstoffe
und andere wichtige Güter.
Gleichzeitig gibt es neue Gefahren
für die Gesundheit.
Malaria und das Denguefieber
gibt es auch in Deutschland
durch die entsprechenden Mücken.
Die Menschen sind gereizt,
haben Angst vor der Zukunft.
Diese Verteilungskämpfe kochen sich
zu einem großen Konflikt hoch,
der irgendwann zu explodieren droht.
Und ein neuer Weltkrieg ist plötzlich
gar nicht mehr so unrealistisch.
Ein Weltkrieg um Ressourcen.
Und die Natur, die ist am Boden.
Wo früher mal der Amazonas stand
und Heimat für viele Tiere
und Pflanzenarten war,
ist fast überall Wüste.
Die Meere sind durch
das Korallensterben und die Erwärmung
so aus dem Gleichgewicht, dass Fische
weniger Nahrung finden und sterben.
Riesige grüne Algenteppiche
durchziehen die Ozeane,
saugen den Sauerstoff aus dem Wasser.
In den Flüssen und Seen
sieht es nicht besser aus.
Jedes Jahr sterben
Hunderte Tierarten aus.
Andere verbreiten sich
dafür umso mehr.
Pflanzenschädlinge,
die kaum natürlich Feinde haben,
fressen alles,
was ihnen in den Weg kommt.
Puh! Erst mal durchatmen.
Wie gesagt, das ist
das negativste realistische Szenario
aus dem aktuellen Bericht
des Weltklimarats,
ergänzt durch weitere Punkte.
Wie wahrscheinlich
ist dieses Szenario denn wirklich?
Das ist schwierig zu sagen.
Einerseits warnen der Weltklimarat
und andere Experten schon länger,
dass die bisherigen Anstrengungen
nicht reichen.
Die Annahme dahinter: Selbst wenn
alle Staaten ihre Zusagen
aus dem Pariser Klimaabkommen
einhalten, ist das zu wenig.
Man müsste mehr machen
und sich auf ein Klimaziel
von 1,5 Grad konzentrieren.
Andererseits haben diese Szenarien
eine entscheidende Sache
nicht ausreichend mit einkalkuliert,
nämlich Innovationen.
Wer weiß, vielleicht wird
in absehbarer Zukunft
eine sehr effektive Methode gefunden,
mit der man CO2 beseitigen kann
oder mit der sich die Kipppunkte
bearbeiten lassen,
in zehn, 20, 30 Jahren.
Vielleicht gibt es Erfindungen,
die den Klimawandel
so effektiv verlangsamen, dass die
Erderwärmung kein Problem mehr ist.
Was natürlich auch sein kann:
Vielleicht entwickeln sich die Dinge
ganz anders als gedacht.
Außerdem gibt es Zweifel
an der Theorie,
dass der Klimawandel zwangsläufig
zu sozialen Konflikten führen muss.
Das schreibt die Wirtschaftsexpertin
Nina Michaelis in ihrer Studie
"Klimawandel und Konflikte".
Sie warnt davor vor zu
alarmistisch Vorhersagen und meint,
es könnte auch gut sein,
dass die Gefahr, die allen droht,
die Menschen eher zusammenrücken
lässt als sie auseinanderbringt.
Möglich ist natürlich auch,
dass eines
der optimistischeren Szenarios
aus dem Bericht
des Weltklimarats eintrifft
und die Menschheit den Klimawandel
irgendwie in den Griff bekommt.
Wenn euch diese verschiedenen
Szenarien interessieren,
schaut in die Infobox.
Dort ist der Bericht verlinkt.
Nehmt euch Zeit, der ist sehr lang.
Dann natürlich die Frage:
Was heißt das jetzt für uns?
Können wir alles
auf uns zukommen lassen
und weitermachen wie bisher,
weil's nicht so schlimm ist?
Das wäre eher der falsche Schluss.
Es muss definitiv mehr getan werden,
da sind sich
die meisten Experten einig.
Entscheidend ist:
Wie viel und was genau?
Da ist es, würde ich zumindest sagen,
das ist meine Meinung,
immer klug,
auf die Wissenschaft zu hören
und deren Ratschläge
richtig einzuordnen.
Einfach nach Gefühl zu handeln
oder wie es einem grade passt,
das wäre in diesem Fall
der falsche Weg.
Und wir brauchen Innovationen,
um die Gefahr zu minimieren.
Gute zukunftsfähige Ideen,
die möglichst nachhaltig sind.
Wie seht ihr das denn?
Sagt ihr:
Ja, das wäre der richtige Plan.
Seht ihr das ganz anders, sagt ihr:
Kein großes Problem.
Schreibt's gerne in die Kommentare.
Hier findet ihr einen Faktencheck
rund um den Klimawandel.
Und direkt darunter etwas
zu der Frage:
Was passiert,
wenn bei uns Krieg ausbricht?
Danke für Zuschauen.
Und bis zum nächsten Mal.